>> Greg: WAS CHOOSING KAMALA
OF BITTER PILL FOR THE CHIEF OF
THORACIC SURGERY, DR. JOE?
IT'S FUNNY BECAUSE SHE'S NOT.
SO FUNNY.
THE VP PICK WITH THE ANNOYING
LAUGH WAS NOT THE CHOICE OF
BIDEN'S BETTER HALF.
ACCORDING TO AN UPCOMING BOOK
FROM TWO "NEW YORK TIMES"
REPORTERS WHO TOGETHER DO THE
JOB OF ONE, FIRST LETTING JILL
BIDEN WAS AGAINST HER HUSBAND
USING KAMALA HARRIS AS HIS
RUNNING MATE AFTER SHE ATTACKED
HIM DURING THE PRIMARY DEBATE.
THIS WOULD HAVE BEEN A GREAT
STORY TO BREAK IN 2020 INCIDENT
SITTING ON IT FOR TWO YEARS BUT
THEN HE WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO SELL
THIS BOOK.
ALLEGEDLY AFTER LEARNING KAMALA
WAS THE LEAD CANDIDATE JILL SAID
"THERE ARE MILLIONS OF PEOPLE IN
THE UNITED STATES."
THAT'S TRUE.
SO FAR, SO GOOD.
WHY DO WE HAVE TO CHOOSE THE ONE
WHO ATTACKED JOE?
DOES SHE HAVE A POINT?
LET'S LOOK BACK.
>> IT WAS HURTFUL.
TO HEAR YOU TALK ABOUT THE
REPUTATIONS OF TWO UNITED STATES
SENATORS WHO BUILT THEIR
REPUTATIONS AND CAREER ON THE
SEGREGATION OF RACE IN THIS
COUNTRY.
YOU ALSO WORKED WITH THEM TO
OPPOSE BUSING.
THERE WAS A LITTLE GIRL IN
CALIFORNIA WHO WAS PART OF THE
SECOND CLASS TO INTEGRATE HER
PUBLIC SCHOOL, AND SHE WAS BUSED
TO SCHOOL EVERYDAY.
AND THAT LITTLE GIRL WAS ME.
>> Greg: I CAN SEE JOEL'S
POINT.
COULDN'T KEEP HIM LOCKED IN A
BASEMENT OF FACE THAT KIND OF
USE.
DO KAMALA AND JILL GET ALONG
NOW?
HERE'S TAPE.
[YOWLING]
THEY DON'T LIKE EACH OTHER.
DOES IT MATTER?
NOT REALLY BECAUSE ANYTHING
JOE BIDEN DOES IS OUT OF HIS
HANDS.
THOSE IN CONTROL BELIEF KAMALA
GAVE JOE THE BEST CHANCE TO WIN
MEGAN PICKING HER WOULD SHOW THE
COUNTRY HE COULD BE A FORGIVING
AND UNIFYING LEADER.
IT'S NOT LIKE HE REMEMBERS THE
DEBATE.
JILL VERSUS KAMALA, THAT MUST BE
AWKWARD FOR HIM SINCE HE THINKS
BOTH ARE THE PRESIDENT.
>> LOOK, LOOK, COME ON, MAN.
THE LADIES DON'T GET ALONG.
I'VE GOT TO STICK WITH MY WIFE.
SHE IS A DOCTOR.
DID YOU EVER HEAR THIS?
AN APPLE A DAY KEEPS THE DOCTOR
AWAY.
NOT HER.
TO TELL YOU THE TRUTH,
VICE PRESIDENT, FIRST LADY, AND
MIX THEM UP.
NOT THE PEOPLE.
I KNOW MY WIFE.
SHE IS THE BLONDE.
BUT THE JOB.
THE JOB.
LET'S FACE IT.
NEITHER ONE OF THEM DOES
ANYTHING.
I HAD ONE OF THE JOBS MYSELF I
THINK.
KAMALA, SHE IS HARMLESS EXCEPT
FOR THE LAUGH.
EVERY TIME SHE LAUGHS, I WANT TO
SMASH MY HEAD ON THE RESOLUTE
DESK.
>> Greg: VIVEK, ARE YOU
SURPRISED AT HOW POORLY KAMALA
HAS PERFORMED AS VP?
>> I'M NOT SURPRISED.
SHE HAS DELIVERED ON THAT
EXPECTATION.
IN THE DEBATE PERFORMANCE, SHE
TRIED TO POST TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ON NATIONAL TELEVISION AS
A VICTIM IS A WOMAN OF COLOR
OR WHATEVER.
THIS IS A KID OF TENURED
PROFESSORS.
AN OLDER SISTER WHO WENT TO
STANFORD LAW SCHOOL.
ENDED UP TAKING A DIFFERENT
PATH.
IT IS THE FAKERY.
JILL BIDEN, IF SHE HAD THE GOOD
SENSE TO TELL JOE NOT TO TELL
KAMALA, SHE DID EARN THAT
DOCTOR.
KAMALA HARRIS, THAT WAS NOT MY
EXPECTATION.
JOE SHOULDN'T HAVE GONE WITH HER
BUT HE IS SADDLED WITH HER NOW.
>> Greg: KAT, WHY DIDN'T HE
LISTEN TO HIS SPOUSE?
THE FACT IS SHE WAS RIGHT.
THIS COULD HAVE --
MUST BE SAYING I TOLD YOU SO BUT
HE DOESN'T KNOW WHAT SHE'S
TALKING ABOUT.
I TOLD YOU SO.
HE DOESN'T KNOW.
>> PROBABLY WASN'T ALLOWED TO
LISTEN TO HER.
I DON'T KNOW.
I GUESS HE MUST'VE HAD SOME
CONCERNS.
JILL HAD SOME CONCERNS.
NONE OF THEM WERE WHAT THEY
SHOULD'VE ACTUALLY BEEN WORRIED
ABOUT WHICH IS THAT SHE'S JUST
NOT GOOD AT DOING STUFF.
OR AT SAYING STUFF.
AND SHE DOESN'T REALLY SEEM TO
CARE EITHER.
SHE WANTS ALL OF THIS POWER AND
RESPECT WITHOUT ANY
RESPONSIBILITY.
SHE JUST GOES PLACES AND LAUGHS
AT INAPPROPRIATE MOMENTS.
THAT'S THE ONLY TIME YOU EVER
SEE HER.
>> Greg: I FIND THAT VERY
ENTERTAINING.
WE WERE LISTENING TO HER.
WHAT DID YOU SAY?
SHE NEEDS BONGOS.
>> YOU LOST ME AGAIN.
WHERE ARE THE BONGOS?
BUT IT'S MONDAY.
GOT A HAIRCUT.
>> Greg: CAN ONLY DO ONE THING
IN THE DAY.
GOT TO RUN MY MONDAY ERRAND.
YES, I'M A PRODUCER BUT BUSY.
>> SPEAKING OF AARONS, THIS IS
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU BOX
YOURSELF IN.
HE HAD TWO CHOICES.
STACEY ABRAMS AND HER AND SHE
WAS MORE EXPERIENCED BECAUSE
THEY SAID THEY WERE GOING TO
PICK A WOMAN OF COLOR TO BE VP.
INSTEAD OF SAYING WE ARE GOING
TO PICK THE BEST CHOICE.
EVEN THOUGH BOTH CANDIDATES,
ALTHOUGH GREAT IN THEIR OWN
WAYS, ONE WAS UNSUCCESSFUL IN A
POLITICAL BID.
THE OTHER ONE COMPETING AGAINST
HIM IN THE CAMPAIGN SHOWED SHE
WAS UNELECTABLE.
BOTH SHOWED THEY WERE NOT GOOD
CHOICES TO BE VP BASED ON
PERFORMANCE BUT PERFORMANCE
DOESN'T MATTER.
THE ONLY ONE -- HIS WIFE WHO
KNOWS HIM BETTER THAN ANYONE
ELSE, KNOWS HIS FAILINGS.
OF COURSE WAS UPSET WITH
SOMEBODY THERE WAS GOING TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF HIM AND BE RUDE AND
NOT PARTICIPATE WHICH IS WHAT
SHE'S DOING.
I THINK SHE'S CAPABLE OF DOING
THINGS IF SHE'S SO CHOOSES.
BUT SHE'S MORE INTERESTED IN
WATCHING THE HOUSE BURNED DOWN
AND ACTUALLY HELP.
SHE'S WAITING FOR HIM TO GET
MOVED OUT.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU
PICK OFFICE INSIDE OF OF THIS.
>> Greg: I THINK --
>> CLASSIC '80 CINEMA.
WEEKEND AT BERNIE'S.
JUST HAS TO BE THERE.
NO ONE EXPECTS HIM TO DO
ANYTHING OR BE GOOD IN ANYTHING.
THE WHOLE IDEA WAS YOU KNOW WHO
HE IS AND HE IS THERE.
MAJOR LEAGUE.
ARGUABLY THE BEST SPORTS MOVIE
OF ALL TIME.
CHARLIE SHEEN AND WESLEY SNIPES
AMONG THEIR FINEST WORK.
THEY TAKE THE ABSOLUTE --
>> HAPPY GILMORE IS THE BEST
SPORTS MOVIE.
>> HAPPY GILMORE IS A TOP FIVE
BUT I THINK MAJOR-LEAGUE IS A
BETTER MOVIE.
>> WHY HAVEN'T I SEEN IT?
>> YOU WERE SAYING.
>> MAJOR-LEAGUE, THE WHOLE
PREMISE IS THEY ARE TRYING TO
PICK THE ABSOLUTE WORST TEAM
POSSIBLE SO THEY CAN RELOCATE
FROM CLEVELAND TO MIAMI.
IT'S AS THOUGH THEY ARE RUNNING
A COMPETITION TO PICK THE WORST
VICE PRESIDENT THEY COULD WHEN
IT COMES TO LIKABILITY, POLL
NUMBERS.
THE BORDER CZAR, LITERALLY LYING
TO THE FACE OF LESTER HOLT
SAYING WE HAVE BEEN TO THE
BORDER.
LADY, I'M GOING TO HELP YOU OUT
A LOT BUT I CAN'T HELP YOU OUT
THAT MUCH.
YOU HAVE NOT BEEN TO THE BORDER.
SHE IS LIKE THE MAJOR-LEAGUE
VICE PRESIDENTS.
>> Greg: THE REAL WINNER HERE
IS, DOES ANYBODY HERE KNOW THE
NAME OF KAMALA SPOUSE?
COULD YOU PICK HIM OUT OF A
LINEUP.
>> IS IT DON'T?
>> Greg: YES!
HOW DID YOU KNOW THE NAME DOWN?
I THINK HIS NAME IS DOUG.
ONLY THE FIRST GUY WOULD BE
NAMED DOG.
>> FIRST GENTLEMAN.
>> ASSUMING HE IS GENTLEMAN.
>> DO YOU THINK THEY DO COUPLES
THINGS TOGETHER?
>> PROBABLY NOT.
>> PICTIONARY.
DIFFERENT AGE GROUPS.
I DON'T KNOW.
SICK LEAVE GOT TO HAVE FOUR
PEOPLE.
>> Greg: I MEANT THE TWO
COUPLES.
THE FOUR OF THEM.
>> NOT EVEN A LITTLE BIT.
THEY DON'T EVEN CROSS IN THE
HALLWAYS.
THEY TAKE TURNS IN THE COMMUNAL
KITCHEN.